[Music]
what is up everybody
it's Monday hey you know that means
Garfield isn't here Oh or he's asleep
Matt - nobody likes I don't like Mondays
either I mean I don't dislike Mondays
mondays are in bad mondays are what you
make of them anyways hi guys from Persia
and I'm joined by Tony Tony is in the
office along with a bunch of other
people who aren't usually in the office
because they're at different places of
gamespot around the world which is
really exciting everyone's in the
offices like the family reunion it feels
like almost definitely I definitely
walked in this morning you know what
yeah Mondays aren't all bad I walked in
this morning I got to see people that I
only get to see when I'm out here so
exactly and today we are going to be
playing picks the cat which is not
really a new game but it's new to switch
it's on switch now so we're gonna be
checking it out I personally have not
played this game before and I saw the
trailer and my first reaction was this
is bomberman cats right I mean that's
new to both of us you know that first
impressions kind of yeah if there's
anything I've learned like since working
here is that there are so many games I
have not tried and games that I tried
and I end up really really liking so
that is a blessing for being here it's a
lesson for anybody who just sticks you
know with one kind of game something you
didn't expect to love and then hey Joe
I'm sure I'm definitely you know guilty
that - that I'll find a game or two that
I just completely fall in love with and
then I just don't stop playing it and
new stuff comes out and new games come
out and I'm like I should be trying it
that's that's fire I'm one for me right
now
I know the switch has been killing it so
a little bit later on we're gonna be
trying some Australian snacks very
interesting stuff here stuff I've never
tried before
and like I said we have a lot of not
really like new faces the game spot but
new to me because I'm new here in
general and I have met anybody and
they're all the way from like we have
people all the way from Australia - so I
think it's cool got some snacks we're
gonna try those out late
but not yet not yet I'm still mentally
preparing myself we're gonna try out
some do I need to connect my I think I
may have one over here yeah so okay I
connected boom we're good now yeah okay
sweet so let's try this out let's go to
play okay might be able to do
this looks like yeah that looks you
wanna see what it's about it or we
wanted to jump in head-to-head
immediately okay yeah let's let's try it
okay let's see what let's see what
happens there might be some okay there
we go boom alright and then okay I'm
already in there we go yeah all right
but yes you guys happy Monday oh wait
what
uh-huh oh we're gonna have to we have to
unlock some stuff huh see you we got
here okay so we'll try it head to head
and then we'll go an arcade maybe you
know run some single-player to unlock
something we can check the rules that's
probably correct probably good thing to
look at collect ammo push to shoot okay
okay and then - okay so you can use your
ammo to shoot or - that's interesting
easy-peasy Elektra shots okay win three
rounds all right so you want to you want
to shoot him and then charge a new one
that looks like okay I like these little
these little like that
all right cutest ammo okay what I will
looks good to you we got cortex infra
well that looks simple yeah probably
good to start with yeah yeah yeah unless
we'll start used unless all these are
suddenly gonna fall away it looks like
they might just we'll see oh I guess
we're gonna get the rules anyway it's up
Kevin cool shank Adam says Australian
snacks covered bugs and roomy ah this
looks pretty good and there are
definitely no bugs on the tables I think
are all right although one of these is a
very very cute koala bear on it yeah no
kangaroo but we do look we have some
humans and then some other just
indiscriminate sheep caramello koala
yeah I like it
alright okay what's this platform in the
middle dude oh dang already okay so this
just kind of automatically moves like
guys get me some ammo Mike likes not
like that boom I'm like Yoshi
Oh my eggs are you ran into my am okay
what's this oh no oh I don't know what
that purple does but I want to loading
loading okay oh wait what was my dad oh
oh it's like oh it's like a little mini
one
oh we just like trapped each other in
here basically it's like a I got sudden
oh my god oh my god what's up mystical
nisha welcome back welcome back Shing
happy Monday oh this is something I do
every Monday I make a mini goal for
myself so that by the end of the week I
accomplishment accomplish it and I can
feel good about myself so let's hear it
Sony what's your goal of the week let's
see you know typically what I do for us
is a lot of news related stuff if people
are here in the chat they're probably
familiar with our GameSpot news updates
hear my voice a lot on those oh hi I
want to charge you know all right
and so you know well not here let's mix
it up let's get involved in some other
things you know I don't stream out of
that office so we get to do that while
we're here yes you know just sort of
collab with people that don't often get
to as you said we got staff all around
the world so people I only really get to
hang out with along here so making the
most of that inside and outside of the
office you know that's that's my goal
so how many offices in total are here it
was just likes Australian office is a
New York office London office London
office oh snap oh that's interesting if
I like hit your ammo chain it like
breaks everything off no
my eggs yes so San Francisco office
obviously is where we are New York
office London office Sydney office and
then we've got people just kind work
from there Oh
from their various homes around the
country this game definitely has some
snake
esque elements yeah you pick up your
ammo and then you run around but you
can't like do a 180 because you got your
eggs in your pocket obvious and it's one
of those where so you just kind of you
just move automatically it's gonna
choose the direction right like a
pac-man kind of thing okay while I'm
showing off the controller - that's a
yeah look in the Stamper and I just know
I get some purple eggs those ones over
there yeah these are the missiles I
didn't get a chance to see what the
green did holding what's I know you have
those missiles I'm trying to stay out of
that way all right
there's some more eggs Oh Oh ting oh I
think there's a cool-down between I can
actually yeah you can't just like
rapidly fire them all off all right okay
so that doesn't become like a little
arena unless we both go in there all
right oh oh ding Oh jookin Oh No what's
this deal with it oh you please live up
okay so the green is a mine good to know
noted I definitely would have went to
pick it up yeah well I think you dropped
it unless you're in London I don't know
that's tricky
all right
oh the missile doesn't go through that
little middle part I was trying to like
time that oh dang I don't know if I drop
there dude you ran into loop all right
maybe a little bolt
maybe a little violent blowing it heads
off heads we're just like little wind-up
RC cars sort of no suicides with your
job in you also alright so imma let you
take the reins check out some of these
arcade cuz I did see a bunch of really
cool arcade option okay so let's check
those out while I pull up some deets for
our viewers where they're asking some
questions like how much this is on
switch and whatnot okay there's like
little challenges
alright collect all the eggs for
dropping them off okay let's try it out
nice noise unless we can do two-player
no it's okay now we're looking more like
a cat a little bit okay okay all right
it's completely even the little avatar
yeah is this game on mobile as far as I
know no it just recently came out for us
which I believe but it's been out for a
while it's also available on Xbox one
PlayStation and on Steam if you don't
have a switch like me although I really
want one and the one that belongs in the
office I've practically you know I'm
like the foster parent for laughing have
you been interested in the switch light
or anything like that any of the new
models that they're coming out with
honestly I think that I personally like
the regular switch because you know you
can take the controllers offs like two
you know two controllers and I don't
know I just like the idea of docking it
and stuff like that and then still being
able to use these little controllers
whereas I'm not sure if like the lie
version it's gonna like give you those
capabilities like you might be able to
still dock it but so my understanding is
no it does not talk at all
that's like a very oh okay so it's
becoming a little more of a puzzle then
because possible to hit my own tail
there oh look did you block yourself off
getting it yeah I wondered about that
blocks um so you so you cannot dock it
the new one you can still register other
controllers with it so you're not just
stuck to the ones on the side although
it I believe it also does not have a
kickstand so I'm not really sure how you
prop it up if you've got other things
attached to it or other controllers
assigned to it oh boy I mean if there's
that one now then there will be one ya
know someone's gonna make some
third-party fix for sure it's kind of
cool because it's like the arena keeps
getting smaller and smaller and I can do
a 180 in this mode actually we couldn't
do it maybe when you have the Ducks on
you know it's probably cuz I have the
ducks behind me okay yeah how do you
Scout wisdom what is that oh did you get
a bunch um
yes i you know this much like school I
kind of I play a hand hold like guy
honestly like 99% of the time I feel
like I dock it when I'm taking it
somewhere to like show somebody else
right visiting a relative or something
is like that's the only time it's
actually docked otherwise completely
handheld so I completely see the appeal
oh no no oh oh you just move on he's a
lonely lonely cat no eggs man I thought
I was gonna like do that over it just
lets me keep going
I feel like this probably would be a
really cool game on mobile actually yes
pretty straightforward erection right
snake was like one of the original
mobile games back in the day on the I'm
your Nokia I was just about to say the
little Nextel or everything was callin
you know key phone Zera your sidekicks
I remember how excited I was to get that
phone with a keyboard but yeah I mean
I've owned like a bunch of different DS
versions so I think I've passed the
point where I'm like man I want every
version of this and more of like alright
if I can get this one item because
obviously switch games and switch like
game like there's not gonna be like a
switch light exclusive game so I should
be okay if I just get the normal switch
anyways alright these I don't know what
any of this stuff oh you can change your
hair okay that's what that is I was like
I don't know what Lord Doom is but it
sounds intimidating okay Lord to do we
are playing picks the cat and we are
currently playing this on the switch so
if you guys are interested trial or doom
I guess yeah so this just released on
the 8th for the switch but it's been on
for a while on PlayStation Xbox and PC
there's just overall really adorable
game and also kind of therapeutic right
like you know simple enough or you're
just I'm kind of just running through
the blocks standing out right like I
don't have to put much thought into this
sometimes those are my most favorite
games oh yeah which again kind of why I
can see it working well on mobile you
know you just need to kill some time
just relax for a little bit yeah I mean
I've recently been blessed with a very
nice phone but I've always been somebody
who's been like I refuse to spend so
much money on a phone but you know I got
really lucky and I got an awesome phone
and now I'm like I just want to play all
the mobile games now you know I you know
I kind of felt that way about phones for
a while like why would you spend so much
on a phone you know and then someone
pointed out that's nowadays that's the
device that you kind of ensure you use
it the most so like if you're gonna be
looking at it the most it's always sort
of in your hand and with you why not
just spend the money you know right
especially most of them run so well now
that you can use them like many
computers yeah
this scheme is trip
me out a little bit because you ever
watch those gifts where they're like
they zoom out of like one little city in
zooming in the country and it's the
planet in this universe yeah ones that
like loops forever yeah I like it
oh this little stage on the outside like
a little maze yeah I like oh I'm still
mini okay let's don't feel all of you
died I've had never really heard of this
game before either but it looks cool I
don't know what's up with those skulls
but they look very dangerous yeah saying
we don't run into this they're coming in
they're in little room there so that's
all right no back out baby oh oh we're
zooming out now oh oh we're really
pulling back now we've done it the gift
has come full circle
whoop oh this is where we started okay
so fever okay this is where we start all
right gonna keep looping the gift player
dude says a cat with a pac-man mouth
perfection it's true that was definitely
what sold me on putting this game on the
stream how it was like always see where
I need to go well I remember cats except
it's it's I feel like it's a a melting
pot of like a bunch of old school games
that we all love yeah like definitely
the snake ball we got immediately ducks
in a row that's a oh okay I'm still
going that's uh that's a phrase or
something isn't it like oh yeah oh yeah
yeah get things in order
okay uh I have information now of all
the different modes so arena mode which
is something we played a little bit of
at the beginning okay you play against
your friends collect as many eggs as
possible to use them as ammo to blast
your opponents I mean friends away this
is literally what the website says only
the most skilled player or luckiest
we're not so sure will be
last one standing up to four players can
join in on the fun you guys know me I
love me some co-op games we played um
heave-ho
last week me and Josh hilarious and
super fun indie co-op game you guys
should definitely check it out
arcade mode hatch as many ducklings as
possible to always go deeper and deeper
into a grid of infinity whoo that's what
this is called the grid of infinity are
these randomly generated them like will
this actually go on forever that's
interesting no see the grid of infinity
so we'll see lead them to safe zones
watch out for walls and enemies and get
the highest score possible but truth be
told your worst enemy here is yourself
which true we already saw that that is
very true the Ducks trapped us and in GG
nostalgia mode tired of all that modern
and jnana shart let's dive into some
good ol 30s atmosphere gather the number
of ducklings required to finish each
level if you're quick enough you'll get
a bonus by getting them all before the
goat can eat the flower yes because
there is a whole menagerie drinking
words and animals now I don't know
what's going on this is probably one of
the most wild descriptions I love it and
then laboratory solve the puzzle they
have a puzzle mode I love puzzle mode
it's the same laboratory solve the
puzzles and as few moose as you can to
get the best results he won't be able to
stop moving unless you hit a wall so
watch out where you're going see that
tells me I can up against the wall and
take my time so great so great that was
interesting so that my little duckling
could also be harmed by the skulls it
wasn't just me so a lot of timing
involved there exactly
let's alright what's this goat eating a
flower thing that you were totally
reading and not making up on the spot
while I was distracted nostalgia move
and that's in nostalgia mode so we we
tried out some our key trade off some
arena you can check out nostalgia in
laboratory next
maybe we should eat some snacks before I
we we have I mean we have plenty here
oMG you guys okay so we cello player
dude and I agree with you diet this is a
goofy game and I love it oh okay let's
uh for a quick second
look at these snacks oh boy got a lot
going on here so we've got these are
called wagon wheels I've got over here
fantails
he's called she goes we got carmella
koalas cherry ripe and then three
different flavors uh just called shapes
they're just called shape they're just
called shapes one of which we will save
till the end because this is the
Vegemite and cheese flavored shape and
Vegemite is like the quintessential
Australian thing I've never what is it's
it's like a savory spread is my
understanding
looks like Nutella but whereas Nutella
is a sweet kind of thing a Vegemite is a
very like salty savory kind of deal I've
never tried it myself but that's I that
needs to be right closer I feel like
okay yeah it sounds good and we want to
start with with savory or sweet here
what would it was chat want what are we
starting with something sweet or
something well we don't have too many
savory option I kind of feel like we
should save all the shapes for last okay
just go through them right because
sometimes we need a lot of sweet stuff
you got a neutralize it with some savory
so like we might need to do that alright
let's go with something so let's go
these little gummies because they're
simple okay cool
the chicos fridge which they really do
look like little interesting they're so
cute
okay Cheers
it's like yeah very chewy but it's like
chocolate flavor which is interesting
it's like a chocolate twizzler that's
what I'm getting out of that mm-hmm
cool I don't know if I like this like
I'm gonna be honest all Twizzlers just
kind of taste like slightly flavored
rubber to me
not a big twizzler person
and so it's kind of what I get out of
that started with the chilliest thing
apparently all right we'll give you it
will give you a second there all right
so it's the next one these are called
fan tails and the wrapper has like in
movie trivia on it oh yeah oh I already
see Orlando Bloom on my wrapper so we're
gonna go ahead and yeah oh this is okay
so it gives you a description I guess
who the person is Oh God all right here
you go you ready for a little quiz yes
all right
these are long though well I'm not going
through all this but this is an actress
born June 22nd 1949 Marilyn Monroe no
not quite
let's see you know what she is uh she's
the most nominated male actress ever
I'll just give you that heart excuse me
the female actress most nominated female
actress mm-hmm
Meryl Streep that's her that's her you
already said you saw Orlando Bloom so I
know what you're oh okay I'll say I'll
say the answer is not Orlando Bloom but
I'll save those only sentence she and
actor Orlando Bloom have a son together
named Flynn I don't know I don't know
glooms partner is let's see if the chat
knows while we try this all right man
tails I have chosen again a very chewy
candy
sorry chat it's like chocolate I don't
know what they are oh my god I like this
it's good it's like a milk dud but so
sticky mm-hmm all right the answer is
Miranda Kerr by the way okay we tried to
snacks we'll see the rest for later
while I'm still chewing we got a whole
smorgasbord all right I just clicked on
the laboratory let's see how this
actually works
mm-hmm
mm-hmm oh this is like um like those
Zelda puzzles where you move on the ice
right so you have to pick the right
place to go where the wall will stop you
just in time oh oh and that's like the
movie counter above okay so this is like
that mode you're talking about we try to
do it in as few moves oh right right
all right I finally finished chewing my
fantail Sam it's really good it's
definitely milk dud ask this is fun
though trying Australian snacks mm-hmm
do you want a game is puzzles to go oh
heck yeah please don't make me go to
Walmart for candy all right we had swell
moves here hmm all right I think I got
how many bubbles to those sad clouds
right sleeping bubbles have twelve moves
to do this well I think I don't know if
that's a limit or if that's just what
we'll see I just will find out if you
take more than twelve I know you mess it
up okay okay oh and I can hit Y to reset
noted I have already made a grave
mistake no actually I don't I think
you're oh I can't go okay I didn't know
that interesting
no I won is joy again yeah well we
unlocked Joker samples whatever that
okay yeah yeah
[Music]
okay me the girls yeah yeah you clear we
got it yeah
nice yeah this reminds me of I think
Pokemon had some similar puzzles too
there were like some some elite four or
like Victory Road kind of situations
where you're you were doing exactly this
where you you stepped on the ice and you
continue to move forward until you hit a
wall
those are always very tricky especially
for young me playing ready I know I'm
like young me had no idea you think
about that you ever like you play a game
or you like you solve a puzzle in a game
you're like if this come out five ten
years ago I would never been able to
figure this out
seriously no way do I have to have all
of them actually it seems like yeah this
is tricky okay but you can go through
until you have them all right let's
let's do run - mm-hmm I don't know how
you get there I was gonna say if you
could like maybe get the bottom five and
then knock out the the five like little
cloudy faces first like I wonder if you
just need to have that same same amount
like let's find out what happens okay so
you do need them all regardless
interesting huh I wonder what a joker
does it look like we have the option
there may be next next time we'll see oh
oh I got it I got it yeah you got it -
oh yeah talk about that like opening
move
yeah nice this is what we do here we
just provide happiness okay what is this
scary red ball down here at the bottom
and then are there only one way to find
out I know
I feel like I already went the wrong way
let's restart I was gonna say I would
have been a different way but you are
playing so it is your choice to make one
more time let's just see what the red
guys about yeah cool
Oh set me up for failure
alright so wait looks like we gotta get
the other guy first then right because
you're gonna be bounced to right over to
the face okay I think I got it
what's it I'll just tell you if you do
what I would have done
I'm really analyzing this right now
actually I should analyze it from start
one instead of okay we have a suggestion
to try Estonian candy sometime thing I
don't know I don't believe we have any
there's no game for Estonia office yet
what yeah maybe one day yes I've always
been curious to try I want to say it's
Sweden Sweden I believe has a lot of
like rock salt candies mmm yeah it's
like a gummy but like it's covered in
salt interesting yeah it might be
Swedish yeah
all right I have oh no cuz that would
take you over the faces okay can you do
a 180 in this if you hit a walk and go
back the same direction I think so okay
then if that's the case then I think I
got it just probably not with a bubble
in your hand yeah yeah that's a good
point
hmm oh you can okay perfect all right
now yeah cool it's now it's just a
matter of oh I see so once you have all
five that's when they get happy and you
can actually have something happy right
Norma these bubbles are freaking cute
okay okay I think it's it's neat that
each little mode has its own protagonist
whatever you want to call these little
these little dudes right like we you
know multiplayer we had our little RC
cars and this one we've got little gummy
I could've did this better I got it but
it passed it no okay do we get okay so
what I need to do so you've got to get
that this guy in the top right first
because you
right which is I think the trick here
let's see Croatian candies honestly I'm
so curious now all these all these
Eastern European countries yeah okay
dang I wish I didn't bump me up I mean
it's the same deal well it bumps you the
whole until you hit a wall right
[Music]
bully to vibes only another good comment
still some rumors swirling about that
one game guides tips this is a little
game called picks the cat's just came
out on switch last week yeah last week I
didn't I did that even worse two steps
worse than the front you know what all
right well they're only gonna get
trickier these are getting good these
are getting good uh what was the price
on them oh yeah the price for this on
switch is sign into your Nintendo
account put all your personal
information up we will find out this one
a shot while you're looking it up
exactly teamwork because ready give the
people the information that they deserve
mmm okay so you can't do so you could do
what any before cuz you were on the same
space as the bubble but when it's right
me like this I can't do it exactly okay
oh this is they give you 16 moves to do
this yeah this is a tricky one okay all
right
got it nice Dean oh look I blinked and
it was completed it's all it's just it's
all about that first move once you get
that done oh dang
okay Croatian in Estonia crochets doing
it southern European countries my
mistake I'm not as familiar with
European geography as I should be
honestly geography is not my strong
suits
oh there bubbles make your own wall
there all right we're learning we're
learning new things which means I bet I
just the kind of a spiral oh maybe not
hmm it just got tricky they were setting
you up they were like see how easy look
I've got more moves so maybe oh I see
you need to go back that left away
somehow so that when you go up you can
you're right you're right mm-hmm those
happy face right yes the that's where
that just doesn't show you right there
on the page oh yeah there are you right
there $79.99 that is a seal by the way
if you would like to own this on switch
it is 799 which is pretty good I'm
thinking to myself now mm-hmm
all right let's just make I'm just gonna
make some moves and then we're gonna go
from there
interesting well now I'm just going in
circles
okay oh no you can go back like did you
get it laughs yeah go down like after
you get all oh yeah I see it now yeah
that one extra little square well cuz
this I like how it wraps around here but
then let you go which is interesting
yep so so oh man because I wanted that's
gonna send your oh yeah yeah yeah
endless lets okay oh wait okay yep okay
boom there it is and look we got okay I
guess that twenty-fifths I thought we
beat it by one I thought we got a is
that a birdie or an eagle I don't recall
the golf term when your well I would
assume eagle because it sounds like big
compliment you know Eagles
oh all right well no that's not the way
to do it's all about that first you
might have been able to go down mm-hmm
this is a tricky thing as once you have
the bubbles like then you've been those
other spaces are off-limits to you till
you get all the bubbles this is
interesting this is tricky
let's
[Music]
I feel like this is still the right
opener yeah maybe damn yeah and then
public oh you've trapped yourself let's
see what a joker does because I'm I just
how do I use a joker I can't go to the
left next one no it doesn't look like we
want to use you Joe oh oh it's just it's
just skip the level that's okay I
thought it was like a hint or something
gotcha I did too yeah all right let's
just
oh nice this is actually a description
from the pasta games website which here
which are the devs buying pics cat
pac-man and snake had an offspring and
its various phases are in the mini game
modes of picks a cat so we were totally
very accurate yes well okay we've messed
this up again okay now go left and then
and then down okay and then left again
okay yeah then we can do this loop all
right cool okay all right
nice good call good call all right
okay Oh progress maybe okay all right
yes then 10 all right we got it
nice teamwork
do you work yes all right I just want to
see what those other modes are about yes
cuz there's still one we haven't done
right exactly I'm about eating a
nostalgia oh look at this
hey here's your gift ready all right are
you uh you are you firmly in the gift
camp gift not Jeff yes that whole that
whole argument I don't like that
argument I know it's a needless argument
but I will say this gif is right it is
right
Oh nostalgia mode Oh looks like we gotta
get a high score first all right well
before we try that let's try more of
these snacks for the old snack plate
alright gonna ruin my lunch for this man
I know you lunch
oh this candy will be our lunch I know
all right
well we just had a caramel thing so how
about cherry next all right a cherry
right boy
fun fact I don't even like cherry if I'm
still gonna try this do it for the
stream yes for the stream and for our
Australian friends in the office oh man
this smells like nothing but cherries
and chocolate
there's also coconut I do smell the
coconut - it's like I almond joy oh all
right funny you're not big on cherry I
despise coconut but it's all good this
is a cherry almond joy yeah this is like
that one piece of chocolate in the whole
heart box that like has a feeling like
this and it's like there's only ever
like one and you that's the one you end
up picking by accident like you're
hoping for anything else yeah just just
what all the candies just it wouldn't be
that bad you just label him well yeah on
that one
we'll have to have to pick like a
favorite when this is all said and done
I think students do these wagon wheels I
don't know if I can wheels I don't know
why they're called wagon wheels these
are just like filled with a bunch of
they're gonna lag and wheels and there's
a parrot on it branding you know that's
great all right all right
wagon wheels hmm it's like
really good a lot of different textures
in that like top part was like real soft
and fluffy and like a crunchy base
mm-hmm yeah all right like hazelnut
yeah everything in like a crunch bar I
suggest we do this we'll finish these
koalas now and then we can finish the
show everything around three of just all
the shapes how about that uranium let's
this is the last sweet item yeah and
then we're moving on I'm already like
well like this little guy though he's a
little guy come on focus so yeah then
someone asked about kangaroo meat
earlier didn't they said yeah no
kangaroo but you have a quality look the
Candy's a little cool ah oh yeah I guess
I got him look at oh look at how happy
this thing is this guy he's almost as
happy as pix account when we get to
puzzles right and we're gonna um
he's definitely happy but also looks
really creepy and we don't buy this at
all for it
oh good a soft chocolate here I think I
like the best that's really good this is
good this is good that's something you
get in your Easter basket yep alright
let's save the savory snacks for later
back to the game I'm gonna go out with
the Vegemite yeah all right well we need
750,000 in arcades unlock nostalgia yeah
where do we at right now
oh it's a high score okay let's okay
like any mode well the starter might be
the easier when you get the high score
in though if we want to go for well you
beat pixel score pretty easily in the
starter so drugs it's already at 755
seemed probably people it's do a quick
look at the and whatever we don't look
at Leroy hello to here welcome to the
stream happy Monday
oh dang it's already oh yeah we started
half an hour we did later than usual I
was like it's already almost time doctor
or lady by this time
let's go with the witch doctor yeah
hopefully the witch doctor can give us a
little extra little extra mojo for this
get this high score sugar is definitely
giving me some extra mojo yeah well for
me being on you know East Coast time
typically I've got just so much more
extra energy being out here with all you
guys right I'm saying when I moved out
here mm-hmm
I was waking up like it 5 6 a.m. every
day feeling good I was like oh man look
at me I'll productive waking up early
I'm like this would actually be like 9
o'clock all right gotta get this high
score gotta fight the goat Danica's
nostalgia no it sounds so cool
oh no okay we're all right almost I
almost messed it up ooh so nostalgia moe
it's a little bit different it says here
that you do not want to run into a wall
mmm so wall also means you losing 70
levels in nostalgia 70 levels that is a
lot of levels you guys for so many
martial artists and some of these I
actually didn't eat the whole thing like
the cherry one bite of that and then the
the caramel oh Anthony koalas ate half
of that one that's why I was witch
doctor I was like I just ate the head
off of a koala that feels like a very
witch doctor thing for me to do right
now you know what we're doing pretty
okay with the score here it looks like
right yeah but yeah that is cool 70
levels and that's just a nostalgia mode
yeah all right so it seems like it's
kind of it's all about the streak I
think a hundred different puzzles in the
laboratory you know what I just notice
that I didn't see before there's a time
limit
hello I didn't even see it before
because you were so good you didn't even
need it before
well we didn't hit it which I think
means I'm not that good
oh no I probably really no all right
well we push on to keep on keepin on
combo breaker great tournament by the
way if you guys are ever interested oh
yeah you you were just at Evo weren't
you
indeed that was pretty great as always
I've heard that it is being there is one
of the trickiest ways to actually watch
everything yeah it's sure there's always
so much going on and if you're not like
hardcore paying attention to that
schedule it's very easy to miss
something hmm
but hey if you manage that's totally
cool to you like there were six streams
I think simultaneously yeah and um I
mean when you're at home you can just do
multi switch and like catch everything
and not worry about it but when you're
there it's way more difficult to watch
everything but luckily you know the
first few days it's like pools and then
towards like the last few days it starts
getting a little bit easier to manage
just because there's less let's come to
it or you know there's still a lot but
you know not as many things all going on
at the same time like on a Friday or
something oops
alright well we're still we're still
alive it's a good thing yeah we got well
you know the time limit did get me last
time that's that's why it stopped okay
what is your what is your fighting game
of choice that would probably be Marvel
3 that would be Marvel 3 girl and
schoolgirls those are my fighting games
of choice although I do enjoy me some
Lucia right now she's new to Street
Fighter 5 and she looks really cool I
like didn't really get to the lab route
too much but I want to you soon but I've
been seeing everybody else like putting
in work showing off these combos online
I'm like dang she
cool see that's cool honestly I feel
like that's what I was missing out of
like Street Fighter characters in
general for five I hadn't really seen
too many I really seen any characters I
really liked you know I like characters
that have like weird mechanics or like
you know utility or you know cool and
interesting things about them that you
know makes them fun to play like Wesker
you know yeah I was like his game plans
are like command throws and whatnot and
that's really fun although in Marvel
like sometimes that's really hard to do
so mm-hmm but it's cool
okay so I'm learning I'm learning new
mechanics a little little things like if
you start dropping off the ducklings
before you have all the eggs it looks
like they're like maybe just worth less
points oh now your time is running well
we do not get the high score I am uh I
am just terrible at fighting games so I
tend to go with just smash brothers hey
that's funny my I do not play I'm not
good at it but you know I feel like it's
one of the biggest ones for sure yeah
and I mean it's kind of sort of just
consider almost like a separate thing
anyway buy a lot of that community isn't
it just because it's so different
yeah the lifelong to be is smashing
fighting yeah yeah I mean there's no
harm and whatever the answer is yes play
it like who cares
honestly it's been like a debate as old
as time yet you know smash closeout Evo
this year and had them less insurance
it's like what can you really say it's
almost like the is like he is a hot dog
sandwich debate and it's like who cares
just eat it you know that's there you go
that's my hot take I guess I never
really thought about that about that
question you never had that posed to you
before no the hot dog sandwich debate
because it's like you know a sub is very
similar to
a hot dog sure you know hot dog meat on
a sandwich hot document
I guess that would just be a hot dog not
a different thing right it's like when
you say like you want a hot dog isn't
that just what like the weenies are
called yeah once you know there's a
actually there's a comedian by the name
of Mike Kaplan who he has a he has a bit
where he talks about sometimes the thing
like these fewer words to say more so
like if you set a hot dog you're
picturing the hole right but if I say
hot dog bun now all you're picturing is
the bread yeah yes he's a pretty good
comedian smash brothers though yeah I'm
terrible at it but they did recently
release the the hero from Dragon Quest
right oh my gosh and he's been causing
quite a stir because it's um it's a
fighter with rng yeah he's got that like
special command menu that it's literally
a random command from the game that you
get to do right all right I don't wanna
ruin myself here again but I'm probably
going to sit same one that I mentioned
every time oh well um this is an Evo I'm
not going for uh Evo chimp picks the cat
well I mean all sorts of games could
play that right like you can you can
find sort of random rooms with random
games all right so maybe maybe some word
Evo maybe someone's playing this
somewhere they're you know they've got
to be I do love me some Windjammers win
dreamers - is that supposed yeah I was
just gonna say I've been hearing about
this Windjammers - whose is that was an
iron galaxy making out I don't remember
well I don't know buddy I thought it was
iron galaxy that um
that did that the the HD whatever it was
that we got over that game the other
year or two ago mm-hmm
I thought it was maybe than making the
sequel I remember oh no that was dot EMU
who made it I'm just I've just got on
myself it's mixed up I guess but yeah
when jammers - is happening and that's
cool and says yes a hot dog is just a
special sandwich
agreed absolutely there's uh someone
made oh no oh my goodness oh oh I mean
oh it's like pac-man fever I can okay
oh now yes that's a ton of points right
there all right I wish I'd I was like
this is either gonna be really cool or
it's gonna immediately end this this
streak we got like super happy no that's
all right there's more eggs here to go
we're learning we're learning more about
what is your favorite version or what's
your favorite what do they call it how
do you like your eggs cooked sunny-side
up so any sign of noise
absolutely the tastiest way in my
because then you can oh I've really
messed that up thinking about eggs
sunny-side up totally you can you know
dip your toast down and the yolk and
everything it's not it's oh man it's the
best just the York everywhere mm-hmm
I like overeasy it's which is like
pretty much sunny-side up but yeah it's
just like once like yeah a little bit of
extra cook is going on there I'm also a
big fan of the the eggs benedict oh you
got hollandaise sauce Tony I'm not a get
these points bro all right here let's do
this all right
I'm not gonna think about breakfast I'm
just gonna when I hone in on this if you
if you get these points we will eat some
shapes
anyways Oh buddy that's like a brand of
chips just called chips Vegemite that
sounds like
you know the VeggieTales supervillain
I've not thought about VeggieTales in
sometimes alright I don't need if these
are the easy ones I don't know why I'm
getting all trading on these these
aren't so bad alright
I just gotta think when I get to that
one that I mess up every time that's
when I really gotta like hone in on it
you know all right
the grid of infinity that's still so
like really cool all right easy perfect
it says I don't really see a way to not
get all the eggs first on this but like
I'm noticing it's sort of okay I had a
theory about the eggs that I just
disproved
well when you go over the circle it like
cracks the other egg so I thought oh
well maybe those are worth less points
after that but it looked like it gave me
750 regardless it was from a cracked egg
so there probably is just to say you
didn't get the perfect oh yes yeah
that's totally a maybe there's just a
point bonus for perfect time olá right
back tactical dr what's your favorite
halo tactical be are putting you on the
spot I mean you gotta be RN tourney and
that's first thing I'm gonna think lots
of juice from Halo games out there but
there is only one real answer all right
this is the one this is the law okay
yeah lever ass it up no no your oh
you're good you're good
we're just gonna yeah yeah I won't get
the perfect but I won't break my combo
which is the more important thing right
and look at all these new duckies do we
need them you're like a mama cat because
they all these little duckies Oh Lord
back in the combo he speeds up all right
oh no run out right when you thought I
was going for there I'm gonna pack me in
that skull and then oh well alright we
got plenty of time still we got what's a
blue-eyed tech welcome to have a Monday
which doctor is top tier voice just
saying okay alright progress yeah we're
doing good now hundred twenty four
seconds now that I know I can be like a
little less I don't have to like be so
perfect with these as long as they all
get delivered all right fine oops
alright get that perfect oh all right
this one got me last time so I just got
a part of our Australian snacks over
here hey look at that score we're
getting there
oh yeah we are close don't hit the mines
yes now that we know we can't fever
those oh I should have gone back just
come back for it that's okay
it's fine it's fine we're still that
score still looks pretty good good more
than a minute all this pressure you've
got this oh yeah look at it look at that
score now I think we're slamming these
perfect sand we're good ooh another 25
Kate bends on bands on bands all right
we're in we're new stuff we're in new
levels now I haven't been to these
before this is a alright this I think
there's gonna be the money shot right
here oh no oh oh we saved it No
oh it looks so good before that -
there's gonna be the hero
yesterday I was gonna deliver all the
ducks and then nope
all right this is this is like curves
this is a weird one they start throwing
these and I don't even know what to do
you're good all right
there are no shapes or curves that can
stop fix the cash thanks witch doctor
yeah no I knew it was broken but thanks
anyway oh my god seven seconds really
need 50k more run pics run you know well
we got real close they're not real close
we think should we try it should we try
one more runner what what do you do here
do you need some energy from the shapes
yeah let's let's take the power Vegemite
let's do it by the power of Vegemite
wait so that's the one for last though
yeah we've got the power of pizza BBQ
and Vegemite Pizza our barbecue look I'm
gonna go with the pizza one first pizza
first pizza first
these are just called shapes shapes
yeah that's pizza that's pizza and
actually tastes like thin crust pizza
but just the crust at the end of it yeah
it tastes like that like a pizza pizza
flavor combos it's funny that this one's
barbeque when there's definitely like
green flakes on it like parsley and
stuff like you would think this is the
pizza one it tastes a lot like the pizza
one although that could just be because
they just ate the pizza ones okay I
didn't notice this with the other two
the barbecue one definitely tastes like
pizza or garlic bread or something all
right Vegemite I didn't notice this with
the other two but these are in the shape
of Australia Wow that is how real
Vegemite is that because the other ones
were not in the shape of Australia
Vegemite Vegemite
that'd be really good if that's what
Vegemite tastes like I'm in totally now
is the best one I think the remains of
our Australian snack testing the
aftermath of yeah all right well I think
you against gamespot Australia yeah
[ __ ] that about - China - uh II D and
Jess and Eddie over there bring it over
all right I'm ready now we got to do
this man come on we gotta unlock
nostalgia mode we got half an hour okay
we can do this
yeah half an hour I got tons of time
then half an hour but we can do this
hold on
let's go for the perfect yeah perfect
every time I was gonna see him all right
I can we is all just strolling taking a
walk and then later it's like ah it's a
zit give me some skull pick Scott is so
hardcore when I get a fever Ives my
ghostly when he gets a fever skull
oh yeah so the more perfect we can get
the better and all right
all these little all these little rules
we're learning as we go along little
tricks yeah I heard it here first pro
picks the cat please only use are the
picks the cat Pro League plays top ten
twenty nineteen yeah just just remember
when picks the cat shows up at Evo next
year yeah yeah yeah we brought him first
all right we're not getting a perfect on
this but that's okay better than better
than ruining the combo exactly there
will be more perfect to get yeah I do
like the soundtrack just a nice kind of
a little fun little jaunt yeah for
delivering duckling sub-genre of music
what is that low five beats we got a fun
little John's for delivering ducklings
there we go we go all right
because those skulls are just there to
foreshadow that more skulls will arrive
all right perfect
all right this is this is the one no
don't give it to me now that's the worst
time for me to get it even when I mess
up every time but I messed that one up
last time anyways and we were okay so
yeah at least we got it for a little
ducky but I didn't get then the fever
came in movie ver oh okay see that like
speed meter up there I wonder it when
that fills is that one fever comes in I
think so there's a lot a lot of HUD
elements here that I Rea not paid much
attention to
he felt real good about that perfect
yeah somebody's I guess you kind of
can't get a perfect on cuz like this one
there's no way to cross to the other
side without dropping off you know I
mean you gotta win back outside and
moved around you're right yeah okay pro
strats like you said yeah takes a cat
Pro League
Oh oh wait wait wait wait
it's feyza that is so come here noise
ooh these pro players are you too far
from cracking skulls just go back a few
stages easy wait
yeah long enough boom headshot yes oh
man completely cleared the plane man
that's that might have just turned the
whole thing around okay that was the
moneymaker right there alright
I'm glad when you do hit a walnut at
least like give you a second to recover
from it right there like I know by one
duct he'll was just too long
it was literally only one duck right
there oh yeah and we have plenty of time
you would literally have to mess up
every single one for the next like don't
underestimate hold my beer hold my
Vegemite by the power of the Vegemite I
have all them and might if we pulled it
off yes looks terrifying out there
it's a giant all right come on I just
saw yeah I just got snakes by alright oh
yeah we're gonna get it perfect on this
one oh I don't know what happened there
but I will take it heck yeah the Ducks
they waddled out of the way a just in
time
oh my feet darn it I was gonna back with
fever and oh well yeah and correct some
where did it look at the score yes all
right
told you easy time to spare I love him
the combo breaks now
the audience gets real sorry my life oh
yeah whatever it's missed out good time
I like how they were like your only move
walking to the spike oh the only one
layer deeper than last time 222 thank
you
you heard it here first there want to I
didn't mean to restart you you take it
over for a nostalgia mode oh snap I've
got I've got a stir arcade mode it's uh
you right you right your turn
we did it y'all new but this one right
oh I love this already yeah reach target
egg counter this is just snake save the
flower before the goat chomps it to make
it perfect
what okay oh I see okay this kind of
seems like it's just gonna be stayin
yeah I love this look
I love this oh no okay see oh he's so
cute though okay this presentation is
awesome I know this girl's got a little
top hat this is oh this is great this is
my new favorite mode I love to look at
this little like sound effects to when
you've got a like are you waiting for us
yeah oh yeah he is so cute look at that
face
it looks like Felix Felix the house cat
a little bit like the the three mouths
like oh yeah next tattoo you right there
for me borderland oh I can't touch it
okay oh well nevermind I see I see I see
I guess this is just trying to show you
how those work haha yes I love the music
here too
[Music]
okay so the go chummy the flower is just
a fancy way to say there's a timer yeah
no go stop it oh it's me pretty tough to
get it within a time limit though I
probably shouldn't be going oh oh you
hit your target oh thank goodness I
guess maybe they'll just keep spawning
until you hit your target it's not like
wrapping a tenon there's only ten right
Oh
the pigs a little big you're gonna move
all something Oh interesting okay so
we'll start here oh wow that's tricky
yeah I think you're gonna get the bonus
on this one nice that's well you had to
manage all three that was pretty tough I
also jinxed you as soon as I said yeah
how many did they say they had like a
hundred or something like that Arab
seventy yeah
this is tricky managing them all know
their duty visa you're disappointing a
whole family here when you mess it up
maybe the level the whole family yep
[Music]
does this really really catchy music oh
[Music]
you got this you got this
[Music]
and again of one immediately after I
said I'm just gonna use curse that's
gonna be I'm gonna do that the best
thing you can you know scream and just
not talk the cool thing is if I stay
along the walls
they'll like automatically walk and if I
go to like the corners so just like walk
automatically so this presentation
reminds me a little bit of cuphead
actually yes not that every old-timey
cartoon is no mr. Allen well notice mr.
Allen do or is he just hanging out oh
snap I hit him and I'm gonna die you
know I see I was so shocked by what the
owl is gonna do that I did not think
about anything he's gonna tell you a
bunch of information ask you if you got
all that and then you're gonna
accidentally say you didn't he's gonna
say it all over again that was a very I
could have said that joke away better
ocarina of time everybody Kapoor Agra
Bora he's gonna ask you how many likes
about what to who yeah apparently
somebody not somebody I'm sure many
people have done an actual study on that
actually
counted it out I know I think someone
did and it play some crazy outlandish
nun barely in a thousand would it be
weird if I just knew the number off my
head oh it's it's this that would be
great actually
[Music]
this seems like it shouldn't be that
difficult you just gotta you gotta we've
all through yeah yeah it's it's the
timing thing too I think
cuz if you like oh man like this stick
wrong so to speak right miss it it's
like it's all in the timing with this
one
oh so you can just pass through the out
doesn't matter
oh I see now okay
the owl lets me stop and change
directions oh really
yeah it's not like yeah so noted oh
that's very handy it just gives you a
second to think
[Music]
no all right I got I got a high score
you can definitely you got this you can
definitely do this I just wish I could
turn at the right moment the timings a
little tough yeah shoot well they all
just they're also like not pleased with
you when they fly away to whatever got
an achievement if something alright
alright
I should have went up floor you know it
this is fine I understand now
[Music]
no I want to def wanted to cut that
corner I keep missing it it's yeah that
I man that Lehman on joy Condor if ya
oniy you know I will say go back to
switch like that actually it's not just
my concern but that is something I'm
thinking about is like what if that
happens when those things are
permanently attached you know nice he
collects my little duckies oh that's
cool yeah he holds a few they're cute
every time we're the one Road reminded
me of like the Zelda like sliding ice
puzzles this is reminding me there's a
couple in like the the Game Boy Color
Zelda games where you you have to step
over every tile but like just once you
got it you got it you got it oh no I
thought yes I did didn't even need that
all that time didn't even need him
they had a mom is that a son or mine oh
oh boy
they so that they have puzzles in the
game boy zelda games where you have to
go over each tile only once so it's very
similar to that where you know it's like
you got to get the exact right angle
every time nice very patient I like Shep
this has like the the flicker of actual
frames to I think you can see the film
reel on the side whoa-ho-ho
wow that was very close nice okay I got
scared I felt the vibration I thought I
hit something on accidentally you know I
did it right is there the other meals it
plots with you okay oh oh I see okay
okay oh come on you can see there we go
I wonder if they'll work like that ever
gets introduced in like the arcade mode
because I would just be extra crazy I'm
curious to see what's next
hey no but they it looked like they gave
you Joker's in this mode too so like if
need be you can always skip but we
haven't had to skip yet so why start now
make sure my ducks okay I was like ducks
in a row stay in your row these are fun
the the pics
oh we get it picks the cat and the cat
was down here ha ha ha ah I didn't even
notice how exact picks until you just
said that actually this is the M&M
themed level
crap it's a tricky shape up there since
when I was always bad at pac-man see I
would try to like cut a corner and I'd
miss the window when I was a kid my
dentist office had a pacman machine in
it I think that was like the one time in
my life I got kind of good at pac-man
nothing I was at the dentist all the
time it's just a memory of my dentist
having one I always hate going in
dentists they always look at you with
such shame if like any little thing is
out of place I'm good
every time they go they're like hey keep
doing what you're doing and I'm like
thank you
they're like you have a chipped tooth
and you ever come to fix I'm sorry I'm
going on life man great tada we've done
it nice and there are 70 levels in here
by the way Peggy's thank you
well if you do this right you could give
the bonus was that okay nope
so it looks like there'll be more than
you need in this level so that's good
you can just kind of grab a bunch but I
think you can get the bonus on this I
think you can do it
[Music]
so it sounds like an actual horn that
they're playing - that doesn't sound
like this is like MIDI soundtrack or
anything props to them for having real
music thought it was being smart by like
using both sides well I mean I do think
that's the way to do it it's just tricky
when you got so many other ducks the
Ducks are super cute I love them they're
little waddle they're so happy to be
waddling along can I take the long way
around
oh boy
one I need to take more like yeah take
more zigzags around that's probably the
way that's the way to go oh I wanted to
cut that corner around take the easiest
things being difficult for no reason
[Music]
I'm gonna have this music stuck me at
all oh yeah free as I always like movies
that are goalies that's the way to do it
just spiral around the outside sorry
movies like the old school he's like the
notebook and stuff that are like placed
in that time cuz they always have like
the music and everything like me yeah
this you want to try some of these
puzzles out in our last five minutes of
the stream we can go ahead to head some
more yeah we only played like one game
of that and so we shall now that I have
the power of the Vegemite oh man look at
this we got another only did seven that
made me feel like I wanted to do more
just like it see the whole wind up yeah
good twenty-eight-year-old progress look
at this all those eggs we've got almost
3,000 eggs and this time alright that's
pretty easy do it all right if we do
four players can we get people on lion
or okay I don't know let's find out oh
it's well now you know now we know all
right I was trying to say I can change
my color there I guess not all right
well we got a bunch more heck you know
it's that's cool too and all these
little tiny said I want to go with this
one okay this looks chaotic the world's
little arenas oh yeah I'm some guys over
here
Oh others oh boy now I'm leaving mines I
did the same okay so they don't stay up
forever
that's smart I love they amuse Oh busted
yeah oh we both explode we both have the
same idea they're just dropping mines on
each other all right oh man almost
trying to drop that right on you where
you came out I know the timing oh you
have all all mines over there oh no that
is dangerous okay and they don't just
explode on the one space either it looks
like actually
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
all right well you've got a lot more
going on than I do
okay so you can't can shoot online
that's good now oh yeah oh crap
got all the ammo going on oh no get out
of that come on come on pics
oh yeah they're all right oh I guess I
was damaged I'm doing but it's so funny
I don't know I don't think it's damaged
I think it's just literally you got a oh
no
Wade you get oh you were making fire so
you guys cigarettes I just thought you
got me
I wonder if you try to oh oh we're in
now oh oh no oh and we get out of here
oh my god hard to see I just I just I
just dropped them all immediately I was
like one of us I'll hit it and then
it'll be in around okay I really imagine
how fun this is look like Oh with four
people yeah uh-huh
oh my eggs all my sunny-side up eggs
yes Oh
laid them all out I know like I can't
get out that's that's the strategy yes
on this one that's what I wanted to do I
just couldn't get to them my bombs fast
oh you can't go through this got it come
on get out of there is this just how it
works
you can't mash out of this I got it
there we go oh boy time to not walk over
there okay somewhere they have a blast
radios - yeah that was like carpet
bombing you see I just went off
[Music]
ah oh man we both have the right idea
there once the Grenada once that mine
show up it's just it's a whole new
ballgame all hell breaks loose yeah
alright oh dang oh no oh there's so many
oops oops I just ran to wrinkle you do
it much strong red well done
all right
I will say eight bucks a lot of value I
agree
oh no my words oh dang
she's gonna hang out for a second I
thought I was actually stuck for a
moment because then I didn't move all
right well here Aggies gonna hang out
all right whoa all right this is trying
to be real strategic about this man by
which I mean just get all the things and
drop them all apparently that the secret
is just drop a ton of money yeah yeah
wait someone goes in there drop in
brother the door you got it all right
whoa that rounds it up for today for
some GameSpot live hope you guys enjoyed
the stream it's Monday so try to enjoy
your week anyways we will be back
tomorrow for some more action if you
guys haven't heard is gonna be a nice
little update for some apex legends so
that's what's gonna be on the stream
tomorrow make sure you tune in and in
the meantime have a good one you guys
[Music]